I was chatting with the Democracy of
deepmind a couple days ago and he asked
me to ask you about what you first felt
when you saw the the play of alpha zero
like it interesting ideas any creativity
um did you feel fear that the machine is
taking over did you were you inspired
and and you what was going on in your
mind and heart funny thing about damage
is he he doesn't play Chess at all uh
like uh like an AI uh he um plays in a
very very human way no uh I was hugely
inspired when I I saw the games at first
um and in terms of man versus machine I
mean that battle was
was kind of lost for humans even before
I
entered top level chess
um so that's never been an issue uh for
me I never never liked playing against
computers much anyway so so that's
completely fine but it was amazing to
see uh how they quote unquote thought
about Chess and in such a different way
and in a way that you could mistake for
creativity
mistake for Chris strong words uh is a
while to you how many sacrifices it's
willing to make that like sacrifice
pieces and then wait for prolonged
periods of time before doing anything
with that is that is that weird to you
that that's part of Chess no it's one of
the things that's hardest to replicate
as a human as well or at least for my
playing style that usually when I I
sacrifice I feel like I'm you know
I don't do it unless I feel like I'm
getting something like tangible uh in in
return and um like a few moves down the
line a few moves down the line you can
see that you can either retrieve the
material or you can put your opponents
King under pressure or have some very
like very concrete
uh positional Advantage this sort of um
compensates uh for it for instance in
chess so Bishops and knights are fairly
equivalent
um we both give them three points but
Bishops are a little bit better and
especially a bishop pair is a lot better
than than a bishop and a knight so or
especially two knights depends on the
position but like
on average they are so like sacrificing
a pawn in order to get
get a bishop pair that's one of the most
common sacrifices oh you're okay making
that second question yeah I mean it
depends on the situation but generally
that's fine and there are a lot of
openings that are based on that that you
sacrifice upon for the bishop pair and
then eventually it's some sort of
positional equality
um so that's fine but um the way Alpha
zero would
would sacrifice a night or sometimes two
pawns three Pawns
and you can see that it's looking for
some sort of positional domination but
it's
it's hard to understand and it's um it
was really fascinating to see
um yeah in 2019 I was sacrificing a lot
of
a lot of Pawns especially and it was uh
it was a great joy unfortunately it's
not so easy to continue to do that
people
have found more solid opening lines
since that don't allow me to to do that
as often I'm still trying both to get
those positions and still trying to to
learn the art of of sacrificing pieces
so uh them is also made a comment that
was interesting to my Noob chess brain
which is one of the reasons that chess
is fun is because of the quote creative
tension between the bishop and the
Knight so you're talking about this
interesting
um difference between the two pieces
that there's some kind of
how would you convert that I mean that's
like a poetic statement about Chess I
think he said that why is Chespin played
for such a long time why is it so fun to
play at every level that if you can
reduce it to one thing is is it's the
bishop and and the Knight some kind of
weird dynamics that they create in chess
is there any truth to that
it sounds very good I haven't tried a
lot of other games but I tried to play a
little bit of shogi and for my Noob
shogi brain
um comparing it to chess what annoyed me
about that game is how much the pieces
suck basically you have one rook and you
have one Bishop that move like in chess
yeah and the rest of the pieces are
really
not very powerful so I think that's one
of the
attractions of Chess like how powerful
especially the queen
is which interesting I kind of think
makes it makes a lot of fun because you
you think power is more fun than like
variety no there is a variety in chess
as well though just but not much more so
than like like no no no no no no no
that's for
it's like night I mean they all move in
different ways they're all like weird
there's just all these weird patterns
and positions that can emerge the
difference in the pieces create all
kinds of interesting Dynamics I guess is
what I'm trying to say yeah and I guess
it is quite fascinating that
all those years ago they created
the knights and the bishop without
probably realizing that they would be
almost equally equally strong with such
different qualities yeah it's crazy that
this you know the like when you design
computer games
it's it's like an art form it's science
and an art to to balance it you know you
talk about Starcraft and all those games
like so that you can have competitive
play at the highest level with all those
different units and in the case of Chess
it's different pieces and they somehow
designed a game that was super
competitive but there's probably some
kind of natural selection that the chest
would just wouldn't last if it was
designed poorly yeah and I think the the
rules have changed
over time a little a little bit